there are a series of bills popping up
in a bunch of states that would
criminalize
and repress protests of all types
and this is really chilling red alert
authoritarian type stuff in nashville
tennessee lawmakers have put together a
bill
8005-8005 that senate bill and house
bill 8005
already passed the legislature would
make it a class
e felony to camp on state public or
estate or public property
between 10 pm and 7 am now what's the
idea there
the idea is have carte blanche have a
blank slate
to go after protests that will occupy
a plaza for some time or a park for some
time
once 10 pm comes classy felony start
arresting everybody
they are threatening convictions
punishable
by up to six years in prison and the
possible loss
of your voting rights it makes it easier
to charge protesters with theft
if they mark up state buildings with
chalk
a michigan bill will classify
rioting as terrorism now what's the
problem there
uh the line on
rioting is in and of itself up for
debate
this would make anything that you can
call rioting
even if it's not terrorism it would make
acts of quote social and domestic
anarchy punishable by up to 20 years
in prison or a 250 thousand dollar
fine in south dakota the governor signed
into law
stricter penalties for rioting and
inciting a riot now inciting a riot is
pernicious since
animated protesting could conceivably
look like it incited someone to start
rioting
and that's a really broad catch-all that
is being applied there
in louisiana there's a bill on the table
which could mean
15 years in prison for protesting quote
on critical
infrastructure what's the idea there to
repress
protests near a pipeline that
residents in louisiana oppose now there
are many more examples more than 20
states over the last couple of years
have proposed
some of these types of bills the idea is
sometimes to criminalize homelessness
sometimes it's to criminalize protesting
other times it's to restrict
restrict speech in practice although
they claim that's not what they're doing
in theory
and this is the stuff that reminds us
why we need to vote at every level it's
not just presidential but we need
state senates state legislatures
governorships because
those are the origins of a lot of these
bills and those are people
choosing many of the state judges
that might eventually decide on the
legality
of some of these authoritarian
restrictions on protesting
authoritarianism really does not like
protesting we know that from history
now i think it's also important to
remember
that this is not just about new laws you
can weaponize existing laws as well
which is why we need the right mayors
and police chiefs in place
mayors often choosing police chiefs
because
they can take advantage of existing
curfew laws
they can focus on unlawful assembly
angles
on gatherings and on and on so it's not
just about
state legislatures state senates and
governors we need the right mayors
we need to push them to select the right
police chiefs this is much more than the
presidency
by the way it's also really weird
and of course completely hypocritical
that many of the same people stockpiling
weapons
in case the government were to become
tyrannical
are in support of laws cracking down on
unarmed protesters on our saying
well if the gatherings are against the
law these protesters should find some
other way
to uh request redress of their
grievances
what what things are completely
backwards of course
and this is just the latest we have a
voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
uh here's an interesting question about
a word
i've been using lately take a listen